بعد عام من الآن ، هل ستذهب للجلوس
لتناول العشاء في الخارج في مطعم أو
بالداخل في مطعم في سياتل ،
هل ستظل ترتدي
قناعًا هل ستصافح الناس بعد عام
من الآن
أه تعلم أنني سأتبع أيًا كان
الأعراف إذا
لم تكن حول شخص
غير محصن ومعرض لخطر كبير ،
فأنت تعلم إما لأنهم يعانون
من حالات طبية قديمة
للإصابة بالمرض ،
فسنكون قادرين على التراجع عن بعض
هذه الممارسات
أه إذا كنت خارج المكان الذي يوجد فيه  الغرباء
وقد يكون أحدهم من
كبار السن الذين لم يتم تطعيمهم ، يجب عليك
ارتداء قناع ويجب عليك الابتعاد
لأنه لا يزال هناك خطر
أنه حتى عندما يتم
تطعيمك يمكنك الانتقال إلى ذلك الشخص الآخر
كما تعتقد  سأعود إلى
المصافحة ، أعني على الإطلاق أنه هذا
أو أنه مجرد واحد من تلك الأشياء التي
سنحملها دائمًا في المستقبل
حولنا لن يكون لديك نوع
من
يعرف أن هذا سوف  دائما س
حسنًا ، من المثير للاهتمام أن تعرف أن الإنفلونزا
وصلت إلى مستوى قياسي منخفض نظرًا للأشياء التي
فعلناها للحد من انتشار الفيروس التاجي
وطيران في المتوسط الذي تعلم أنه لا
زال يقتل 60000 شخص على الرغم من وج
د لقاح وب
ض المناعة السابقة وما إذا كا
يقول الناس الآن ، يا إلهي
، لم يكن من المهم أن تتصافح
كما تعلم ، لذا دعنا
نتخلى عن ذلك ، فأنت تعلم أنني سأتبع
العرف الاجتماعي
الثاني ، ألا تعرف أن تكون في مكان
بعيد عن الآخر على ذلك اه
تصافحك "  سأصافحكم ، حسنًا ، لقد
فهمت الأمر فقط لإظهار معرفتي بأنني
أفكر دائمًا في
الابتكار التكنولوجي قبل الأشياء الأخرى
التي تعرفها ، وآمل أن نتمكن من التوصل في
العقد القادم إلى
لقاح أه عالمي لجميع
فيروسات كورونا
وليس هذا فقط  وبالمثل
لقاح شامل لجميع أنواع الإنفلونزا
لأن هناك آثارًا سلبية حتى
من نزلات البرد الناتجة عن فيروس كورونا التي
يصاب
بها الأشخاص والأنفلونزا ، نعلم أنه لا سيما عند
النساء الحوامل وأنت تعلم أنني
ذكرت 60 ألف حالة
وفاة وهكذا ih  ope المجتمع الطبي يطمح بشكل
كبير في تشخيص الأدوية
واللقاحات للتخلص بشكل خاص من الكثير من
أمراض الجهاز التنفسي
لأنها تحمل عبئًا سنويًا بالإضافة
إلى مخاطر الوباء